Gráfica la siguiente ecuación "y" igual a 2 por "x" más 2, todo eso al cuadrado - 4.
Déjenme me paso a un lugar donde pueda trabajar.
¡Muy bien! Tenía el polinomio "y" es igual a 2 veces "x" más 2 al cuadrado -4.
Ahora bien noten que en esta forma canónica de la ecuación de la parábola,
este término de aquí siempre es mayor o igual a 0, de modo que el signo de todo este término,
el término que incluya el 2 está determinado por el signo de este número, en este caso como es un número positivo,
esto siempre va a ser un número mayor o igual a 0. Si multiplicó algo
positivo por un número que es mayor o igual a 0, obtengo otro número que es mayor o igual a 0,
de modo que a -4 siempre le estoy sumando un número mayor o igual a 0, por lo tanto si lo que quiero es
obtener el número más chico posible para "y",
entonces lo que tengo que hacer es sumar 0.
Si a -4 le sumo exactamente 0, ese sería el valor más chico que tomaría esta expresión,
¿De dónde puedo concluir que esta función tiene un mínimo?
¿El mínimo en qué punto?
Pues para que esta expresión de aquí se anule, "x" tiene que valer -2, así que
"x" vale -2 y si "x" vale -2, esto se hace 0 y "y" vale sólo -4.
Este es un mínimo y de hecho precisamente es el vértice de la parábola, este es el vértice.
Así que bueno hagamos una pequeña gráfica para ver qué está pasando.
Ahí pongo mi eje "y"
y por acá pongo mi eje "x"
y yo sé que la parábola tiene un mínimo en -2, -4, el vértice está en -2, -4.
¿Y dónde está ese punto? Pues veamos 1,2, ahí está el -2
-1, -2, -3,-4
yo sé que la parábola pasa por este punto que es el -2,  -4
y que aquí es un mínimo, de modo que la parábola se ve algo así.
Se ve algo así,
para poderla graficar completamente voy a hacer una tabla y vamos a encontrar otros 3 valores, para "y".
Todas las parábolas se determinan con 3 puntos, así que esto funciona con cualquier parábola. Veamos vamos a poner aquí
el valor de "x" y aquí el valor de "y"
que es 2 por "x" más 2 al cuadrado -4.
Ya sé que la parábola pasa por -2,
así que -2, -4, así que voy a tomar puntos que estén cerca, vamos a tomarnos -1
-2 y -3
para -2 ya se que el valor de "y" es -4, para -1 ¿Cuánto es?
Para -1 sería -1 más 2 es 1 positivo al cuadrado es 1
2 por 1 es 2, -4 sería -2
- 2 y para -3, -3 más 2 es -1 que al cuadrado es 1
2 por 1 es 2, - 4 de nuevo es -2.
Así que yo sé que en -1 la parábola pasa por
"y" igual a - 2 es decir, este punto de allí es el -1, -2
y simétricamente para "x" igual a -3,
la parábola pasa por -3, -2.
¿Ok? Entonces nuestra parábola se ve algo así.
Bueno y ahí esquive al punto pero tenía que pasar por ese punto, entonces vamos a reacomodar los puntos en el sitio a estas posiciones.
Bien entonces el vértice estaba en -2,-4
-2, -4, en -1  la parábola pasaba por -1, -2
y en -3 la parábola pasaba por
-3, - 2 así que esa debe ser la gráfica. En efecto.